the 22 year old right-hander
was noah last two starts he's been
brilliant 12 and a third he's not
allowed to run
he struck out 13 and allowed only four
base hits oh yeah by the way he's
homered in two straight games as well
looking forward to watching him pitch
tonight
and is ready on this mother's day to try
to pitch the home side to a winning
series
she'll go to work on mccutchen's
underway in atlanta
and cutch on a first pitch out to center
field it's chasing christian mache
he reaches it and for the second
straight sunday
andrew mccutchen is let off the ball
game with a dinger
just like that just like that baby like
i said
i'm the best come on happy mother's day
to that baby
hey hey well on cue partner he is hot as
you said he's raised his
batting average 70 points in the last 10
games
aaron nola with a one-nothing lead
thanks to the home run by andrew
mccutchen
yeah i mean he is uh the total package
he's a true horse three balls of the
strike and the pitch on the way to acuna
that's up and in for ball four and the
braves have a base runner
so the lead off hitter reward now for
freddie freeman
against the phil's age there goes a cuny
a huge jump he's got it stolen easily
lead off fitter in scoring position in a
one-nothing philly's lead with 3-2 pitch
home and freeman lines it back up the
middle of base hit
herrera is up throwing it won't be in
time to cut down acuna and we are tied
one a piece
when we talk about acuna's enthusiasm
you'll see ron washes putting
a dead stop and he'll run right through
it
i don't know if you see him or he's just
that excited to be playing baseball
at second one out for ozzy albee's
and alby sends one toward the gap in
right center
that's gonna bring home freeman easily
to 2-1 atlanta it's ozzie's second
triple of the series
ozzie fell behind in the count he rakes
one into the gap
change up it looked like a flat change
as well might had a little bit of a tail
on it but
stayed on the same plane and ozzy
stroked it to right center field
two down here in the inning and it's up
to dansby to get that run in from third
base
a violent swing rising through the sky
this ball
is out of the ballpark homer number four
for dansby second of the series
and the braves have gotten four across
on nola here in the bottom of the first
inning
and lead four to one so two on and bryce
harper's coming up harper
who before last night had only eight at
bats with a man in scoring position he
had four of them last night
and went over four so he's three for 12
so far this season
got him big strikeout for noah his third
of the game second time he's gotten
harper tonight
so now real muto with runners at first
and second and one away another good one
man is that sharp tonight four
strikeouts for inoa
maybe just a slider that starts right at
him nothing you can do
so it's up to alec ball with two down
that's a little dribbler in front of the
plate contreras has it
jogs down the line toss it to freddie
there's out number three at a good
bounce back by
noah freddy freeman leads off to braves
half of the third
first pitch on the way to freddie that's
it high in the air a towering fly ball
deep left center field at the wall
goodbye
freddie freeman launches his ninth home
run of the season
and he's two for two tonight 5-1 braves
gregorius leads things off in the philly
half of the fourth
and on the first pitch from awaskar
younoa
fly ball for christian pache you know
has been impressive tonight
sharply hit into the shortstop hole for
swanson makes a routine play out of it
two pitches two outs here in the fourth
2-1 pitch into the opposite field ozuna
in the corner to put it away
and it's a quick one two three fourth
hurry and noah
two balls and two strikes pitch all the
way from nola ground ball little number
charging in third is balm he will bare
hand and come up empty
now we base it out of dansby braves
trying to manufacture something for the
bottom of their order here
contreras the number seven hitter with a
man at first and nobody out
got him four strikeouts for aaron nola
tonight one away
brings up christian pache mache fouled
out to first base in his first try
tonight
on the ground for bone to sagura for one
relay back to first in time to double
him up nothing despite the lead off
single in the home fourth
two-two swing and a miss down he goes
miller down on strikes the pinch hitter
and that is strikeout number five for
you know
that'll bring up segura who is flight
out and single to right
2-1 grounded to the left side trouble
backhanded by swanson
throws across his body and got him what
a great play by dansby
way to his right he hasn't allowed for
much momentum
after that
harper sends that the other way for
ozuna
and rio muto is aboard that'll bring up
alec baum
pitch to alec baum is lined into right
center hit it on the screws but right at
christian
pache for route number two here's
gregorious now with two out and real
muto still at first
and deedy sends one into right
has got this one some loud contact but a
scoreless
sixth turned in by inoa ozzy albies will
lead off against ranger suarez
looking for something soft out over the
plate instead gets heat in
perfect pitch riley leads from first
here's the 3-2 pitch swanson swings and
misses he struck him out
the pitch and a swing and a miss got him
to chase
and there's a third strikeout for suarez
no runs one hit
one left we're through six since the
start of last season no
lefty reliever has struck out more than
the 30 year old veteran tyler matsuk
and there's a base hit for hoskins into
left the phillies have their lead off
man on
payoff pitch coming up to herrera ground
ball back to the mound backhand stopped
by magic to second for one to first
for two did that really just happen
how did he catch them without looking at
the baseball just stuck the glove up
behind his head and gloved it
started the double play a gold glove
play for the braves
all around the horn oh my god i mean he
just
flagged that down behind his back austin
reilly
braves had a comfortable lead on a 2-2
hit hard a rock into deep left field
back goes mccutcheon over his head off
the wall
they will give the green light to ozzy
he races around third base
now they throw behind riley they've got
him a run down between second and third
the run will count riley will get the
rbi he's tagged out
and that's how the bottom of the eighth
comes to an end the braves pick up
one more run rbi number eight of the
season for
austin and we head to the ninth with the
braves on top
six to one so two gun with a runner
aboard
and the phil's last chance will come in
the form of reese hoskins
this one's hit out to left marcelo zuna
is there
and the braves have taken the series 6-1
atlanta the final braves take two out of
three in this weekend series with rival
philadelphia